uber uber Mia Mundi well in Australia I
paid a visit and my respects to the
National Centre of indigenous excellence
where I was honored with a traditional
welcome to country ceremony performed by
uncle Graham King and the Impa elder so
that's the song that comes straight from
this ground here no one represents the
new face of indigenous Australia quite
like Adam Briggs a rapper comedy writer
activist and proud member of the your
tea ordination on my arms I got my tribe
Yorta Yorta Yorta Yorta man yeah and
then all my hands is always was always
will be which is like a it's a protest
kind of things that always was always
will be Aboriginal man right I just got
drawn on by my friends and it was happen
to be quite honest right so that all
these tattoos happen when you were
asleep
yep are you hooked up you got lucky yeah
I could have had a bunch of dicks what
is it you're trying to accomplish now
it's about changing the perceptions of
what an indigenous artist can be right I
think in the future of this country I
really do thanks and of course my
opinion carries no weight here
Briggs good on ya good on ya know what
they say it's like patronizing oh so I
just sort of told you - yeah a little
bit brings down the ultimate Cullen
[Laughter]